at the met police saying a firearms  incident uh took place police were  called to reports of a man with a  firearm he was seen to enter a bank and  the bookmakers in marlow's road w8  the armed officers then stopped the  vehicle in which that man was supposed  to have have been  shots were fired and a man sustained  gunshot wounds the london ambulance  service and london air ambulance were  called the man was treated at the scenes  seen but despite the best efforts of the  emergency services he was pronounced  dead this afternoon efforts are  currently underway to confirm his  identity and to inform his next of uh  kin  um if you've been in that area you'll  know that there are a number of road  closures in place  at the moment those are likely to remain  in place for some time  the public is advised not to go to that  area to try and avoid it and worth  saying here that the incident is  absolutely not being treated as  terrorism according to the metropolitan  police there